[Musique]
fabrice dans le film coexister vous
jouez le rôle d'un producteur de musique
ouais et vous allez vous mettre en place
pour le vannetais cependant cette
extrême et juste avant en tant que
producteur de musique est ce que vous
auriez pris ce chanteur regardent le
plus lointain lui pop la foire où il
entre au delà sa garde à toi dans ma
barbe noire comme de la houle la ou les
grenouilles des lacs rouille tous et
toutes à paquereau qui risque de prendre
la trouille envoie les hommes avouent
ils étaient présents comme une cpe jacou
l'a fait pour détruire des biens dans
notre dos que j'aime revoir à chaque
fois mon fabrice c'est celui-là c'est
moi le commises à ses capacités
[Musique]
épatant
sig entrepôts de transports visées
recevoir un truc et on a laissé que
fabrice pour rappel vous admettez le je
vous le dis à chaque fois le comedy
crochet ouais c'est discours de jeunes
d'humoristes sur comédie regarde ça très
très longtemps vous aviez fait
finalistes exactement j'étais déjà très
très drôle ça remonte c'est toi qui
présentait je prendrais ya plus de cash
et là tu me manques ou dans la gueule
j'ai l'impression d'être michel drucker
michel saive a présenté des doses
vraiment de mexes etc et voilà mais tu
étais déjà énorme impact arrivé
finaliste et j'étais pour toi d'ailleurs
le gagnant lui à c'est lui qui a fait 1
touchable il a fait 25 millions
d'entrées à toi de toi chérie
beaucoup sont dans le film trois
religieux fans comme on l'a dit un
groupe de musique on va faire un
blindtest équipe du film contre les
chroniqueurs vous joins également chez
vous mais à chaque fois à tant vouloir
donner la raison va falloir donner la
réponse de manière par des nuls dire
comment d'accord avant d'aller avant
d'accueillir camille combal dans le film
le personnage d'audrey lamy
elle couche assez facilement la plaint
d' aventure du coup avant de nous
répondre vous allez devoir faire une
boîte très sensuelle si vous trouvez le
titre d'accord il va falloir me donner
l'interprète d'accord n'interprète pas
le type parce que l'interprète attention
top sexy sur cette caméra
c'est quoi le titre dieu m'a donné la
foi vous pouvez faire un petit peu sexy
vous abonner quoi à pois pour les donner
la réponse en faisant l'accent un peu à
la réaction du maghreb
d'accord vous en venir c'est qui ceux
qui n'ont pas ni lens à l'action
je crois que c'est nathan cohen incarne
dans le film mais c'est qui qui chante
en allemand florian florent pagny bien
joué bien des il ya des shots de l'enfer
là bas jouer tabasco plus grenat dit on
veut donner la réponse
il va falloir en bois en entier me
donner la réponse après sa chanson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des téléphones
attention petit pour me répondre vous
allez devoir aller sur scène regarder
faire la danse de rabbi jacob avec les
danseurs qui vont donner votre parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du manuel conséquent pour on ira tous au
paradis de michel polnareff
la jamal debbouze qu'on embrasse très
fort qui nous regardent et qui dit vous
ramdjee dit ara musique que sa veste et
canon j'aime beaucoup son style voilà le
tennis aussi ouais merci
[Rires]
gros bisous
on veut répondre allait devoir chanter
la réponse comme si vous étiez dans une
chorale c'est parti il s'agissait c'est
georges brassens chorale au courant sans
doute lorsque c'est être en panne il a
répondu oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention classé spécial ringard vous
allez devoir de me donner la réponse en
faisant en imitant action allez c'est
parti à la regarder d'où est aujourd'hui
non alors c'est qui qui chante ça c'est
docteur docteur c'est un coup de fer
maboul
non mais n'en comptera le banc alors
allez-y clair non mais non mais landreau
est alors allé à cas il s'agissait de
terre
aucun porte une attention avant de
répondre vous allez devoir faire une
confession
allez devoir donner le nom de la
personne autour de la table avec qui
vous avez le plus envie de faire l'amour
et il faut que ce soit vrai d'accord
celui qui donne la réponse
j'aimerais bien que ce soit rachid arhab
[Rires]
alors attention je préfère savoir annie
toinon bas géraldine maillet quoi ouais
c'est ça car mais c'est quoi la réponse
c'est à n'y accorder la bonne du curé
non mais avec qui je couche avec quatre
toiles à 3 tension vous allez devoir me
répondre alors ça c'est très très un
gars aussi en faisant genre une voix
démoniaque puisque je vois
[Rires]
ça du démon mais c'est la salsa du démon
attention le dernier titre vaut cinq
fois et je vous le dis on a vu l'extrait
on va voir leurs extraits du film avec
guillaume de tonquedec on va revoir
l'extrait dans un instant et je vous le
dis il va falloir donner la réponse
il ya deux jeunes hommes là-bas regardez
il va falloir le donner les données
comme guillaume de tonquédec dans le
film à quand la même situation
oui il viendra alors c'est le dire des
cuivres de bent est si vous répondent
il va falloir se mettre en oeuvre nos
deux amis attention vous êtes près
troyes 2-1 top il chanta il chante ça
[Musique]
[Rires]
m
j'espère qu'on pourra y mettez ça mais
alors qui va moi je dit fabrice tourre
amos oz à l'est
[Applaudissements]
allez
oui
alors d'après vous allez devoir nous
donnait donc les mains moites déjà alors
le chanteur c'est là c'était soprano est
alors élu allègera dit le nom mais c'est
le montre dans les faits c'est le
plaisir les gars tension c'est parti de
là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci à tous les cieux bravo à vous tous
eu la jambe à konya pas que parce
qu'elle fut exceptionnelle
[Applaudissements]